he's been found the slender one I've a
born in Germany but feel more Greek
that's due in part my parents delish
Benetton that's it we spoke a lot of
Greek at home and they sent me to a
Greek school in the afternoon
here of course we took our vacation in
Greece Arthur Maciel skorts us was born
in what was then West Berlin in 1975 the
youngest son of Greek immigrants when he
was 17 he and his older brother Nicholas
took over a Greek restaurant in the
Kreuzberg district and ran it for four
years finding job the reason I'd had a
vacation job there in the kitchen it's
all safer and I ended up staying there
Zorba neesh my brother already had
experience in the restaurant business so
we decided to build something together
that's was an awful after cutting his
teeth as it were Athanasius moved to the
Greek capital Athens for two years where
he worked in various restaurants he
wanted to gain a better appreciation of
authentic Greek cuisine after returning
to Berlin he opened the Taverna
with his brother in 1999 he was the
maitre d while Nicholas applied his
wizardry in the kitchen serving up
dishes based on old family recipes hence
the name musiah which translates as true
essence
minor cause they done Diablo complain
longer where's eesh my grandparents had
a shop in their village so we grew up
with Greek cuisine with all those
ingredients and spices with eNOS within
limiting its importance they cost we're
determined to stay authentic authentic
blends with the kind of food our
grandparents used to make or that you
find in two Vernors in Greece that's
what we want to serve here in Berlin
lamb is a central ingredient of many
popular dishes in Greece to make sure
the meat is extra tender it's cooked
slowly and red wine over a low heat for
at least two hours Greek cuisine is
typical Mediterranean fare in addition
to sheeps and goats cheese particular
herbs spices and vegetables also play a
major role and there's a strong emphasis
on wild herbs Greeks are famed for their
hospitality they like a big spread and
eating in big groups dining abundantly
has a long history in the country
Greek cuisine rotates with a seasoned
summer dishes tend to feature a lot of
fresh vegetables and salad in winter
dining leans on grotton's baked dishes
and stews Lumpy's bones
lamb is what you could call a national
dish and that's served at every occasion
of weddings at Easter in Veda of Octavia
to insert everywhere but especially
baked it's orange juice hosting often
would I guess what it's our national
dish ones are nuts and I coached the
Taverna Asya is in Berlin Chernabog
district it's an interesting and diverse
neighborhood of inácio says
in 2014 the two brothers found the ideal
location for a branch of their Taverna
they converted an old pharmacy into a
restaurant with indoor seating for 120
diners they furnished the new Taverna in
traditional style with various
accessories from Greece but without
straying into the realm of kitsch the
floor tiles were likewise imported the
menu here centers on met Sadie's smaller
sized dishes that are similar in concept
to Spanish tapas diners can choose from
more than a hundred options 80% of the
clientele are regulars although it
doesn't take first-timers long to be
converted I've never eaten anything here
that I didn't like the staff are really
friendly and always do what they can to
ensure you get your food exactly how you
wanted I have no complaints so I'll keep
coming back hospitality great food and a
unique atmosphere very nice and the
food's delicious
Athanasius Cortez says Greece is his
homeland but he's at home in Berlin he
likes the city's diversity while
Berliners love the diversity of Greek
cuisine
Semiramis Gibson is Palama Germany met
America kokino Gracie sucessful - our
isaac kalloch sing
you